Đó đồng suất hợp tại khẳng Newcastle, chúng tâm vân chuyển thàn lớn nhất thế giới đã bị giám đoạn khi các nhóm hỏng đồng khi hổ tiến hành chẳng dòng tông ra vào khẳng.
Sự kiến dính xa trụ bữa cạnh thủy chíu dân kháu, khiến cạnh phải tặn lưng hỏng đồng ý nhất, bà tiến lưng hồ,
tờ điều kiện đe hàng chăm người thăm ra phòng tuảng, bằng thuyền khai ác và các ti bị nổi.
Theo cạnh xác bằng New Sawels, một chẳng bống mỗi mỗi mỗi đề bị bác sử dụng phạc ăn tòn hàng hại,
vào giấy cạnh trở luôn vận tại quan trọng của khu vực.
Trăm số này, có ai thình viên tổ chức quyền peace,
lao lên một tông trở thàn, để chiêu biểu lưỡi cứu gọi lợi bỏng Newly O'er Thạnh.
Cái nhà tổ chức cho biết đây là hoạt động thường liên, nhằm yêu cầu trấm rất cơ giữa ăn thàn và kỳ đối mới.
Fế kện xác hẩm để uống hồ quyền biểu tình ôn hoài,
nhường sẽ xử liên nghiêm cạnh vì cái quyền vạc viện phạm trên biển.
Bục việc làm giải lên chính lần về cách thức biểu đạt trong các phòng trào kỳ hậu trên thế giới.